foreign
Studies have shown that some cells and
some organs of both humans and animals
are highly sensitive to radiation which
cells and which organs can be most
affected
x-rays how safe we'll answer those
questions on today's consultation
the University of Illinois at the
medical center Chicago brings you
another program in this series and made
possible in part by a grant from g.d
Cyril and Company
our guests from the Food and Drug
Administration are Dr William Cole
associate director Bureau of
radiological Health Rockville Maryland
and Mr John bilford director Bureau of
radiological Health Rockville Maryland
moderator for this program is Jack
righeimer
[Music]
welcome once again to consultation
program I think one all of us are going
to be very interested in or should be
if any of us have ever had X-rays in the
past year or so
this is a show which is going to talk
about that subject as you heard x-rays
house safe
gentlemen thank you for coming from the
Federal Drug Administration we
appreciate it
Mr wilforth um
let's x-rays talking about the broad
subject of experience that's very very
Broad
What specifically are we going to be
talking about today
well as you know x-rays have been around
for a long time and radiation has been
with us in industry in University
training programs and educational
efforts but I think the most important
area of radiation that we could talk
about the most interest to the public is
the one that concerns radiation in The
Healing Arts x-rays used in diagnosis
this is a fascinating subject in which
one of which I think many of our
listeners perhaps would appreciate
understanding a little more about it and
I'd like to focus in on that particular
subject diagnostic x-rays we'll talk
about the numerical aspects right that's
correct medical and dental okay
could you define for us we always do
this on consultation could you define
for us what is radiation well it's
always a difficult difficult subject to
Define but in its simplest form I think
we can say the radiation is a is a form
of energy
in motion and this energy in motion when
it passes through living material to
cells in our body
has the ability to affect these cells
either rearrange them cause changes in
the structure of the cell or possibly
kill the cell
depending on the amount of radiation
quantity of radiation and the particular
organs that are involved the radiation
can do various biological effects and we
all have different
susceptibilities in response to this
radiation so each we're assigned to do
it each person could relate differently
to different radiations too depending on
the organs that are involved in the
amount of radiation yes
Dr Cole um
as Mr Wilbur said we x-rays medical
x-rays dental X-rays this has been a
thing with us it's been with us for
years and years and years and years and
years and nobody really questioned
whether or anything quotes side effects
and bad effects why all of a sudden are
we concerned Well Jack we are concerned
because in 1970 108 million people had
uh one x-ray or more during that
particular year
and as Mr Belfor said x-rays can produce
some damage to the body
and we divide this damage when it is
produced and the risk is really minimal
into what we call genetic effects
the genetic effects are those that will
show up in subsequent Generations
the ones that of concern to the
individual undergoing the X-ray
examination we call somatic effects
these affects the body itself for
example
uh a woman undergoing an x-ray
examination who is pregnant
or the unborn child is more sensitive to
a radiation than say the mother herself
we are concerned about this type of
X-ray examination
we know that cells are damaged by
radiation but we also know that cells
recover
some are there a viability again some of
their normal existence after the
radiation
one of the things that really bothers us
most of all is what is the effect of
low-level radiation that is
the type of radiation that we get from
the background and in particular from
repeated x-ray examinations
over the years we really don't know what
the long-term effect of this low-level
radiation is
for example
the question of of possible damage came
up when Dr rankman first discovered this
uh modality when
he had must have had some concern about
possible damage because the first x-ray
film that was made was the film of his
wife's hand rather than of his own
what do you take a chance himself I
guess not I guess he decided that he
would have his wife's hand show up first
now I can understand with the when you
mentioned using an example of a pregnant
lady going and have an x-ray because of
the you know unborn child are we saying
there are certain parts of the body
certain organs within the body which can
take X-rays better than other parts
therefore you can x-ray your elbow 40
times more than you could your liver I
don't know I'm just using an example
lines that's right jack certain areas in
certain cells of the body are more
radio-sensitive that is a are damaged
more easily and with less amount of
radiation than others
for example we believe that the
reproductive organs are the gonads it's
called or more sensitive to the effects
of radiation than say the skin for
example that doesn't mean that the skin
is not sensitive to
radiation but less sensitive let's say
the fetus as I mentioned a moment ago is
certainly more sensitive to radiation
and at certain stages of the pregnancy
in the first three months we feel that
the sensitivity is greater than it is in
the last three months I think generally
bill we can say that the more rapid
growing cells are the ones that are more
sensitive to radiation this is why the
skin is perhaps less sensitive than the
Bloods
Supply system which is a rapidly growing
reproducing system because we don't get
radiation on the sun right natural
radiation we get we speak of that as
background radiation Jack we are living
really live in a sea irradiation to some
extent but uh today of course we are
concerned about medical radiation the
second type of tissue that we are
concerned about is the bone marrow where
the red cells and the white cells are
actually manufactured
the most sensitive cell I believe is the
white cell this is the cell it really
protects us against infection
uh the thyroid gland in the neck is
another gland that we feel is more
sensitive in other tissues
for example a weekend we are concerned
that the so-called annual routine full
mouth x-ray
of the teeth is uh possibly could expose
the thyroid gland and we are concerned
about that
and they'll enter the eyes another organ
that we are concerned about it may be
more sensitive than other tissues
so that's about the difference in radio
sensitivity okay so there it is so it's
important to know the part of the body
that you are really x-raying and how
often you should x-ray that particular
part of the body yes um we think that
every effort should be made to protect
the reproductive organs in any type of
X-ray examination and this is very
simply done by the use of lead Shields
and the use of a proper technique which
we'll discuss a little later okay now
you've been giving a case about the um
the Badness of x-rays but x-rays must be
good because we've had him a long time
and I do a wonderful thing as far as
diagnosis is concerned so you better
give the other side a little bit too
well I'm glad you asked that question
Jack because I personally feel that the
benefits uh far outweigh the risk of
this diagnostic test for example
it's been calculated at 70 to 80 percent
of all the diagnoses that are made in
the United States today either in the
hospital or in a doctor's office are
made or confirmed by the use of X-ray
examinations for example it would be
impossible to do any type of a setting
of fractures for example you know
without this modality we calculate and I
saw this in one of our journals that
that will be 50 000 skiers who will have
a fracture this year this is just a
small sample
number of fracture cases that we see
every year without x-ray it would be
impossible to do and get a good result
there's an element of Hazard Jack I
think that I'd like to to mention and
that is the the risk element of
radiation and this is very difficult to
quantitate but I think perhaps if I were
to use the analogy with cigarette
smoking perhaps the viewers would
appreciate this for example
we we know that radiation produces
cancers leukemias it also will shorten
our lifespan we know that for example
cigarettes will increase the risk to
cancer about the cancer of the lungs
now like cigarettes we know that if we I
mean like it in smoking cigarettes we
know that if we we smoke a certain
amount uh we may or may not get lung
cancer it's a risk it's a risk that we
perhaps if we're smokers are willing to
take radiation risk is much the same way
only the risk in this case may be
imposed Upon Us by the The Physician or
the clinician
but the risks are are statistical or
probabilistic as we say for example
the amount of radiation that we might
receive in
from medical radiation perhaps could
increase the incidence of certain
diseases by maybe one in ten thousand
that is if ten thousand people were to
receive this particular x-ray
perhaps one might receive an increased
one might receive a particular disease a
particular type of cancer this is the
order of magnitude and these are not
specific
but now if you look at the
the number of people in the United
States receiving X-rays and practically
all of us almost all 200 million of us
get it sooner or later this means that
well one in ten thousand times two
hundred million it means that there's
probably about 20 000 people in the
United States who may be getting that
particular
disease or illness you see as a result
of the radiation whereas you as an
individual may only receive or have a
probable chance of one in ten thousand
which is a reasonable risk if you have a
broken leg and as a ski and or a skier
talked about but when you use the total
population of the United States that
means there are perhaps 10 20 or more
thousand people of with some sort of
disease or illness perhaps caused by
this radiation that need to be treated
and I think that our job in the Bureau
of radiological Health the Food and Drug
Administration along with our colleagues
in the State Health departments and in
our colleagues in the profession is to
do the best job can to keep the exposure
from these radiations as low as possible
so that the risk is reduced for example
if we could reduce the dose to half of
what it is today we perhaps could cut
that risk by from one in ten thousand to
one in twenty thousand instead of twenty
thousand people in the United States
maybe there's ten thousand in other
words a saving of of life or cancers of
maybe ten thousand per year yeah it is a
right that's right now is becoming
two-edged sword good and bad and it's up
to an agency like yours a Federal Drug
Administration to protect us the
consumer right that's your job I can't
do that you know it's up to you because
I'm not qualified in that area Jack
another example of uh of what I
considered a real benefit is in the use
of pelvimetry pelvimetry is an x-ray
examination that is done on a pregnant
woman to find out whether or not she
will be able to deliver the baby
normally
some years ago this was done in
approximately 20 percent of all the
women that entered the general hospitals
today that is less than five percent
so we feel that our efforts to educate
uh the the possible risk to the the
fetus uh have gone across that this
examination is now used stirring in less
than five percent and also the the
physicians at ordering this examination
when it is really necessary for the
safety and health of the child and the
mother
that we have advised that they have this
done in the last three months of the
pregnancy
because as I mentioned before the fetus
is less sensitive at that stage we're
becoming more sophisticated about X-rays
and where they can be used
when they can be used why they can be
used how they can believe so it's as
simple as that right you use the term
and I think you better explain that low
levels high levels and all and I'm a
little confused I used to we're more
concerned about low level I would think
you'd be more concerned about high level
well low level radiation as I mentioned
Jack concerns with the type of X-ray
examinations we're discussing today the
diagnostic type of X-ray examinations
this is low-level radiation
is the right if we use x-ray in therapy
or treatment of disease this is
considered high level the Cobalt for
example right and where the dose is
measured in thousands of RADS which is a
term used of the absorb dose
so we're talking about two different
things
the the way I assume the public and can
uh the public we the consumer
can get the minimum of risk and have the
the most to benefit is buying
listening to and hoping that the uh
which you are doing with the federal
federal uh agencies like yours FDA is
involved in working with the Physicians
and Radiologists so that we will have a
safer
our x-ray our main reason for existence
is to reduce the unproductive quantity
of X radiation and optimize or get the
most benefit out of the radiation it's
used in diagnosis Jack if I could have
that first slide I think I might make a
point here on I think of the benefits
okay now there are three parts to this
the first is the sound medical judgment
the second is good radiographic
technique
and the third is X-ray equipment
I will discuss uh the medical judgment
and leave the other two optimists to
bilforth
now in
The Taking of an x-ray
a judgment has to be made by the
patient's position as to whether or not
this examination is indicated if it's
necessary yeah is it necessary correct
this is is determined by the physician's
experience
by his education and medical school
by efforts of uh
agencies similar to our own as to what
are the indications for this particular
type of examination
so the first decision is made when an
examination is to be done is made by the
referring position
and we call this medical judgment
the type of examination that we don't
like to see
is when an x-ray examination is done
in a sense by or ordered by a physician
to protect himself of possible
litigation at a subsequent time
the exact number of these cases how many
of them are done in a year is not really
known
but we know that it is really too high
this is particularly true in uh very
soon standard type of fractures
in other words we're just saying the
position is up to Physician's
responsibility to
to say that x-ray is important to have
because I have to find out whether or
not this really is the problem that's
that's right but as I said all too
frequently he feels that if he doesn't
repeat this examination at certain uh
maybe two frequent intervals such as a
fracture of an ankle in a cast
that uh it's possible that maybe
something will slip and he later might
be up for possible malpractice or
litigation so
too frequently uh these examinations are
ordered for that purpose this in our
opinion is is unnecessary okay I don't
want people going into their positions
they have the broken leg and it took two
X-Rays Dr Cole said hey you only should
have taken one we've got to clarify that
you know there may be a reason for
taking the second x-ray too you know you
know that we we're just saying that that
is that is if that is in the intention
of the mind of the position that's not
the proper way of using x-rays that's
correct another another one that we
worry about too is when a patient or an
individual makes a decision himself does
have an x-ray examination we call this
self-referral
for example uh if a individual sees uh
in the parking lot of the shopping
centers the TV Vans he might be tempted
to go in and have an x-ray examination
of his chest
and actually there's really no
indication that this should be done we
feel that only this type of examination
should be done is when there is a sound
medical indication your physician orders
The Faculty I think it's an important Dr
Cole to point out that that these
changes in in judgmental factors are
coming about mainly through the work of
the professions they're involving the
educational institutions to incorporate
these changes and you may mentioned a
bit about the Pediatric fluoroscopy I
think this is a rather dramatic example
of changes that have taken place very
good uh John some some years ago Jack it
was almost a routine for a pediatrician
to fluoroscope a child or an infant
uh on the table
just to check the size of the heart to
check the expansion of their lungs
well excuse me I might interject that
fluoroscopy much higher delivers a much
higher exposure to the to the individual
than just regular radiography okay so
this is quite concerned when fluoroscopy
would be used this was brought to the
attention of the pediatricians and it
was cranked back into the medical school
level that just what can you obtain from
this type of examination using the
fluoroscope
and subsequently the American Academy of
Pediatrics issued a statement to
cautioning all pediatricians to only use
this when it is absolutely indicated and
where possible to use a x-ray film
examination where the the dose is much
less than it is with the fluoroscope
there was this type of thing that we
think through education that we are
making our point for all of us is more
and more educated I got to get to the
technician it's going to say this ties
in very nicely to the question of
technique because we're talking also
about technique and judgment that were
used in this particular procedure what
happens you know if my uh you know the
The Physician makes a proper judgment
and we're going to an assumption because
I'm with Physicians all the time
therefore they make proper judgment and
they go on and we my technician
maybe zaps me a little bit too much
that's a possibility you know I don't
know how do I know it's sort of like
you're deciding to take your take a
picture of your child with your camera
and that's your first judgment the
second the second point of technique you
find out you you left the lens cap on
the camera exactly or you have to retake
the film so our concern here is that the
individuals who are actually adjusting
the machine making the making the
settings on the machine and processing
the film uh use the best information to
get the best quality radiograph and all
too frequently we find that uh there are
there's much room for improvement you
see there's the there's probably a
hundred thousand technologists or
technicians in the country who are
responsible for taking the x-rays most
of these are not Physicians they're
technicians and there's no real
requirement of education for these only
three states in this right now have any
sort of licensure laws for these
individuals wonderful this may means
that in many cases the individual may
walk off the street walking off the
street and be activating the machine so
our concern is and one of the things
we've been doing in the Bureau of
radiological Health has been to place
attention at the educational levels
continuing educational levels working
with the states and the state societies
of technology to improve this yes there
are certain things that we would
emphasize for example the making the
proper selection settings on the machine
just like in your camera you've got to
if you decide to take the picture you've
got to make the proper adjustments or
the exposure is incorrect and if the
exposure is incorrect that may mean the
film would have to be taken over again
the picture would have to be taken over
again secondly like in photography if
the film isn't processed properly you
may also have an ineffective picture
so we're upgrading actually yes and then
thirdly is another interesting area it's
a process we call collimation
collimation is is that device or
mechanism that we use which which limits
the X-ray beam to just the size of the
film now if I could have the first slide
I think that you'll be able to see that
on that slide the top picture shows a
what we facetiously call wall-to-wall
radiography where the technician does
not bother to make the proper
adjustments of his uh x-ray beam and the
beam covers all of the vital organs of
the body and in addition to the film and
of course that radiation which doesn't
strike the film not only uh
destroys some of the quality of the film
but also has a risk of biological damage
so what we try to encourage is the
technician to restrict the area of the
beam to the same size of the film as
shown in the bottom slide in other words
just that point if you want to answer it
right using your Simon allergy I go a
little further about the camera and so
forth whether my camera is lumped up
in this case what if the equipment is
lumped up that's the that's the third
point in the the list of the three that
we had on our first slide and I think
this is extremely important because here
is an area where we have made some
considerable progress over the the past
few years uh and I say we I mean both
the uh the Bureau of radiological Health
but perhaps more significantly our
colleagues in the state radiological
health programs and certainly uh our
colleagues in the profession because
here we can really place a lot of credit
for the improvements the equipment
uh has been inspected in most cases and
is being inspected to date by the state
the federal government has no authority
to inspect equipment in Physician's
office offices now what we do have under
the recently passed radiation control
for health and safety act is the ability
to set performance standards for new
equipment and we have established
performance standards these were
published of August in August of 1972
and will be effective for all new x-ray
machines being manufactured after August
1974 which means all the X-ray equipment
must meet performance certain
performance standards and if I make a
mention of the previous slide of
collimation we have incorporated into
this performance standard a requirement
that this type of collimation be
mandatory for new equipment so that we
hope that we will eliminate all of the
extraneous radiation that was shown in
the top of the previous slide so what
you're saying really gentlemen is the
fact that now we you you made a case for
X-rays and problems of X-rays and the
fact that there is some danger but we're
working towards the right end and things
are becoming much better and you're
having certain protective devices
employed so that we the public you know
shouldn't be that scared I want people
to go around being scared and one way
one way we can stop them from being
scared too besides listing this program
I have some material I can give away and
not I but the Federal Drug
Administration is so happy to give us
away I don't know if you can see this
it's called Uh oh that's good Jack flare
that right up Radiology Health
protection and consumer radiation
protection and be most happy to send
both these both
to you if you will write to us and Cara
consultation Universal Illinois Office
of Public Information post office box
6998 Chicago 606
80 and you can get both copies of these
two pamphlets we'll give you an idea
what is going on and what's your FDA is
doing for you and why they're doing it
we only have about three minutes left
gentlemen and uh that's the reason I
thought I just want to say kind of sum
up a little bit at the end they're
saying that you know you made it in the
beginning kind of made a case to scare
the heck out of all of us that x-ray is
coming and we're going to be worried
about this and vital organs and then you
went on it was very good you kind of
refuted a lot of the things along the
way
no question about the beneficial effects
of radiation of a diagnostic x-rays as
Dr Cole indicated and in the trend in
the future is going to be uh I'm sure
greater our our data from the studies
that we've done show that The increased
radiation is being used at ever
increasing amounts and hopefully for the
better betterment of mankind but at the
same time we must be concerned about
this element of risk and I think if I at
one point I would like the viewers to
appreciate it's the fact that we do have
an effective program we do have an
agency at the federal level and most of
the states are involved at the state
level in doing something about this
keeping this into perspective we also
are working with the professional groups
to bring the excessive amount of
radiation under some degree of control
and I think we can be rather proud of
the accomplishments that have been made
to date
um just one quick question doctor call
you you indicated something about the
Mobile X-Ray it is not a good thing for
us as individuals go in and select and
say I want to you know translate this
should be left up to your position check
the Dynamics of tuberculosis have
changed over the last uh 25 to 30 years
and in some areas of the country
tuberculosis is almost non-existent
and it's for this reason that people who
themselves walk in into these Vans and
have an x-ray examination we think this
is unnecessary x-ray exposure of that
individual and we issued a policy
statement in February of this year
recommending that this type of X-ray
surveys of the general population be
discontinued now the national
tuberculosis and respiratory disease
Association New York came out with the
same policy statement so in a sense we
are recommended that this type of survey
be discontinued I think it's also
important to point out to the viewers
that generally the type of equipment
that's used in these Vans results in a
much higher exposure than the same kind
of a procedure used in a hospital or
Physician's office perhaps as much as as
10 to 100 times more exposure than you
would get for the same type of
diagnostic procedure in an office just
by the nature of the equipment that's
used in these mobile units it gives back
to your three points exactly exactly you
know the uh
thank you very much I want to thank you
ladies and gentlemen watch consultation
I hope you've learned something from
this know a little bit more about x-rays
until we see you again on consultation
the best of health
x-rays how safe has been a program in
the series consultation presented by the
University of Illinois at the medical
center Chicago and made possible in part
by a grant from GD Searle and Company
our guest from The Food and Drug
Administration have been Mr John
bilforth director Bureau of radiological
Health Rockville Maryland and Dr William
Cole associate director Bureau of
radiological Health Rockville Maryland
moderator for this series is Jack
righeimer coordinator of Public Service
radio and television programming this is
Frank Sweeney
[Music]
the preceding program was planned in
cooperation with the department of
health education and Welfare Food and
Drug Administration
foreign